three other cops in the George Floyd
Florida case have been charged with
aiding and abetting a murder and their
job ins charges raised from third to
second degree murder good all now face
40 year terms
Wow no I'm not look I I think the UH
there's real questions about
second-degree murder charge for shovin
because apparently he knew the guy
exactly that's where it gets weird
exactly I mean well he knew him that so
they haven't gone as far as say that he
knew him but they said that he the owner
of the nightclub came out and said they
both worked for me for a year they were
both security guards they didn't I
didn't she said she didn't see them
interact but she knew that the cop was a
hothead
he was macing people regularly holy and
then the other dude worked inside so
they were you know they weren't in the
same one was like a door security one
was like indoor security to like have to
haul people out I think that was George
and so but I mean they worked there for
her for a while you know what man
I I gotta say if you go to a jury mm-hmm
and say these two guys work together for
a year
yeah they may not have interacted I
think a reasonable person is gonna be
like come on yeah exactly what you've
worked it why she said she didn't know
that's that's all I'm saying she wasn't
sure if they had interacted but they
both worked there for years online you
work at a place you know the people that
work exactly the point bringing up is
she can say she's not sure but a
reasonable person's gonna be like nah
like if you worked at a big office
building and then he killed the guy yeah
right come on but but that's why I think
there may actually be an you know here's
a resentment there's often these cases
where they try and give really harsh
charges mm-hmm that never stick and they
wonder why these cops don't get
convicted and they say it's because the
system is protecting itself and it's
like there's a little bit of that maybe
or the charges were too too vicious yes
I didn't excuse me that didn't stick
because of that right if someone if it
were in a lot of these circumstances you
have a cop who freaks out kill somebody
and they say murder and it's like first
of all you have to consider that police
are trained for lethal situations you
know which means they're not going out
for the most part with the intent to
actually kill people and also they
actually deal with lethal situations
right no it's not like
it just suddenly sprung on them they're
trained and they actually have to deal
with this a lot so they go into every
situation thinking that you know like I
gotta be prepared just in case this
turns into a lethal you know situation
so like I you know you got it you got to
look at both sides of that but the fact
is they knew they knew each other we're
all right so what here's the point I was
making when it comes to the line of duty
mm-hmm you might be able to get a
manslaughter charge negligent homicide
or something like that a jurisdiction
because you can't ask someone to take a
lethal weapon and enter situations where
they may die and then call it
premeditated murder you know when
someone dies that's why I was saying it
should be manslaughter
from the beginning oh no no this
shouldn't be well no this is before I'm
finding out right in the beginning I was
like it's clearly manslaughter in the
least right it's manslaughter because a
guy died in his and-and-and yeah and so
here's why I would say that you have a
responsibility so is her with with great
power comes great responsibility yes I
understand you're entering situation you
have lethal force you might use it it
might be wrong and if you get it really
wrong
well you're still responsible someone
said this and the other day and it's a
common saying you're responsible for
every every you know discharge of your
weapon you're responsible for every
bullet and where it ends up I think
that's true for anyone that is holding a
gun in their hand exactly and guess what
the cops would still get leeway because
we asked them to do it for us in this
instance this dude had a guy with his
knee on his neck not supposed to do that
yep and he said don't do that everybody
in our chat was saying no way don't do
that never suppose we had a bunch people
in superjet who were prison guards
mm-hmm we had law enforcement military
they all said no way man we were never
told to do that and yet on there have
been people that are tweeting me in the
Minneapolis Police book they have like
some statues of that this could be the
case like you could do this in certain
situations for kneeling on someone's
neck yeah and it's like I'm like I can't
believe I'm actually reading this you
know yeah I mean could it have been
falsified like someone could have like
made it up and like put it out there
like look you know see he was doing
whatever you know so this is all hearsay
as far as I'm concerned but I am seeing
that now and it's
like is that really the case I don't
know but what my point though is if that
is the case then that's basically them
trying to get him off the charges right
if they said well look it's in the book
see he was just following the book that
that we have written it's like but I'm
saying constant worse than that I think
sometimes you might see trumped-up
charges as a way to get them off yeah
that's right so you've got a cop who
accidentally kills somebody and it's
clearly not going to fall under the
statute and the jury can't convict
because it doesn't meet the guidelines
right so is what people understand when
it goes to a jury trial
they say the question you know the jury
has to answer is under you know say like
first-degree murder did he you know
premeditate and intend to kill this
individual and immediately the jury's
like well no of course not right that's
it not guilty so you got it you got to
make sure you charge them appropriately
yeah and it's it's not annoying but
people people what like the sound of
first-degree murder you know as opposed
to second-degree or a third degree they
think it just sounds like you're going
harder against them it's like no it's
just the appropriate charge right and
that's so important if if we're gonna
get justice for George it's like which I
I want justice for George I don't think
these other cops should be getting forty
year terms that to me is crazy I'm not a
fan of what they did oh these are the
cops who are kneeling on his back they
should have known better yeah and there
and in my opinion that would be like a
manslaughter yeah because they were
actually you know they were challenging
the guy and he was telling him like
basically shut up so basically the other
cops were standing there challenging him
I said you should get off right so
basically there's like statements from
some documents where the guys like one
of the cops is like he's like he's not
even resisting anymore and he's like so
what leave him where he is and like okay
so there's a problem it is tough I think
four years is a bit harsh for people
being stupid but it is fair to point out
just following orders is no excuse no
your new people being stupid leading to
it death is a little bit different than
people being stupid and yeah anything
else happening yeah but isn't a death of
a human you know I do find 40 years
extreme like so so we have this uh well
it says it says here the most severe
charges Larry a maximum sentence afraid
so they wouldn't get 40 years
you know there's that story of the the
two lawyers who apparently threw a
Molotov cocktail and it was uh was like
a thirty year old woman a 32 year old
guy oh yeah you were telling me about
this earlier in New York and they were
lawyers man and everything in front of
their their lives were that's that's a
great deal have the law works
they had a great life mm-hmm man they
fought so hard they did everything right
and other lawyers and then they chose to
make Molotov cocktails just you up to do
what I don't know so but the reason I
bring that up is these cops who are
being charged now and face up to 40
years okay one day they walked into work
everything was normal they probably a
couple doughnuts in a coffee and life
was great mm-hmm and a moment's notice
in a flash now they're facing prison
they're getting death threats people
calling for their heads and their life
is forever changed and that's that
should be a warning to people you can't
take things for granted you've got to be
responsible for yourself you got to know
what you're doing
you got to know what you're getting into
and I take this stuff seriously man I
get really really angry when people play
stupid games near me yeah when I'm in a
car and someone's got road rage
I'll frappe shut your mouth yep do not
put me in your stupid situation if it's
a lotteries tickets chance someone
throws a brick at the car I don't want
to I don't want to orbitals a gun and
just start behind me shooting and that's
Chicago as the Chicago rules you know
you know I know too many people in
Chicago who will run their mouths and
then what happens is they're shooting on
the highway yeah or getting rammed into
or a fight breaks out and I'm like run
off the road and I almost got run over
the road some people were crazy and
Chicago's crazy man I wish I was hanging
out some skateboarders mmm south suburbs
and just because they're stupid [ __ ]
punks yeah this is what really got me
away from the more far left and Arkell
punk people they saw some jocks they
said and so they went got weapons from
their trunk and then chased them off and
I was like yo are you doing it's like we
were here to skate those guys weren't
doing anything and though who cares
they're jocks and I'm like I care
yeah I was like I'm out of this man I'm
gonna be how I'm not gonna hang out with
you man you could play stupid games
there's no reason to be that so you see
these two these these two lawyers stupid
games man could you imagine what's going
through their mind think about this one
day you wake up you make a pot of coffee
you hang out with your friends you watch
you don't know what's what's hot on
Netflix Tiger king yeah just finished
the final episode I guess now that was
broke yeah alright so whatever it is
these these dumb New York hipsters are
doing space force space force is that if
she I don't know that just came out
they're eaten people give it a shot yeah
they're eating a pizza these two lawyers
and then they see riots breaking out
okay and so they're like yo let's put
some let's make some mile tops huh and
then they go and do it and just like
that they drive up in a car and that one
thin line was crossed and their lives
are over rightly so yeah stupid games
stupid prizes man yeah that's it and so
you know I bring you back to this like
it's just it's an idea I've been
thinking about with like how easily your
life will end when you do something dumb
it's easy to see in the riot
I wonder if this woman where this man
was an unwitting [ __ ] let the guy the
guy drive a travel probe apparently I
wonder if she was like come on Collins
do this drive he's like okuu and he's
went along with it I'm not saying it's
true it's true I'm is saying you can't
you know ignore responsibility for
what's happening around you so with
these cops they're getting charged I'm
not surprised
yeah when when you are kneeling on
someone's back mm-hm and you say he's
not resisting and the guy says I don't
care you push him off there what you see
that video where the groom yeah you see
that video where the cop is kneeling on
the guys neck and the riot and they're
screaming get his knee off his neck and
the other cop grabs a knee and pulls him
off awesome yep
there you go it's like that's how easy
it is that yeah just like that yeah rest
of the rioter but these these other cops
they were the they were just mindlessly
derping along then we both had foo just
land this guy's back was dying that's
messed up man you know so the the
medical examiner said that it wasn't
strangulation it was a combination of
the restraint and presenting medical
conditions and then I guess two
pathologists concluded that it was
pressure on I guess the carotid or the
arteries to the neck basically it would
it's it's not strangulation it's like
when you when you compress some of the
blood off from an marine then they die
yeah and that's what he did that's how
that works
so now so let's talk about we'll wrap
this up with the last point about him
knowing him and now second-degree murder
now before before we move on from this
though I do want to ask the question
people are riding for this right mm-hmm
now we're with these guys all these cops
I mean were they gonna face these
charges anyway are people gonna be like
if we didn't try it as crazy as we did
would this have happened I got it I'm
curious you know because it wouldn't
think and you know what it wouldn't have
happened they wouldn't have harassed
they would not have arrested him not the
same they wouldn't have rested him no
okay so here's what needs to happen from
this point forward mm-hmm if I was if I
was the mayor of Minneapolis you know
I'd say what I'd walk out and I'd say
this man will be arrested and charged
based upon the evidence then in front of
us okay and we will address situation
brought to all of us if there is a riot
he will be released immediately and all
charges will be dropped due to conflict
of interest and we will not we will not
capitulate
to threats of violence from anyone
anywhere and mark my words from this day
forward
if you ever riot in response to this we
will drop all charges immediately on
these officers what and like let him out
I'm exaggerating quite a bit the point
I'm trying to make is these people are
rioting and the government said whatever
you want you know they just told the
riders but do it again yeah do it again
who said that
the government the government said we're
so sorry rioters you can do whatever you
want and because you did we will give
you what you asked for
you don't negotiate with terror look at
what's happening about likova but they
are the law-abiding that's what that is
done
right the law-abiding citizens mm-hmm
who has been staying in for months who
shuttered that shed their businesses and
then legally went out and said we want
our businesses back or just I want to go
to church
yeah see obviously they were they were
smeared and defamed and insulted yeah
and the people who broke the rules and
broke the law were defended that's what
you've learned and that is a dangerous
precedent in our society that error
works men seems reminds me of that Star
Trek episode where data asked Picard you
know if we condemn terrorism why is it
so often that it throughout history it
works and then data gives some examples
and Picard's like I don't know
you know some of the most difficult
questions that we've we fought it you
know yeah it was a good episode real
good episode yeah
because fortunately these people know
South Park to the nepo sewed where they
talked about terrorism and then in the
end
comedy central belief to the whole
speech because basically he was like I
learned something today that if you
engage in violence and fear and threaten
people they'll give you whatever you
want it works and all this other stuff
oh man
yo dangerous thinking yeah and this is
what we're getting out of this and I
don't like it I don't like it one bit if
they if they had come out immediately
and said you know listen if there's ever
an instance where this occurs and you
peacefully protest and march through the
streets we will listen if you riot we
shut it down immediately we'll let them
go keep riding all you want man but I'll
tell you what we cannot have a society
where you threaten small business owners
and regular people where a 77 year old
retired police chief dies because he got
the David Oren story got a call yeah son
and he went to check it out and they
killed him for some TVs now we have 13
plus people who have died and they're
going to the rioting worked
oh that's great all you do is walk over
some corpses to get what you wanted
isn't that isn't that isn't that great
yeah more people died we can't have it
man so I don't know if the solution
actually is to say well cut them loose
if you riot but the point I'm making is
you can't give the tip that the rioters
what they want the no riot more because
what happened they riot instead here's
what we want so they gave it to him
they righted more okay well up the
charges they righted more and then they
said we want first-degree murder
it's like negotiating here dude is that
what's happening yeah we're negotiating
you're destroying business setting fires
across the country and that's your
negotiation killing your own people to
killing people good point yeah good
point to fight two cities now anyway man
I'll wrap it up with this in foreign
countries in Middle East
if an American gets kidnapped you use
got you you know the US government
promises sharpen the hammer on them we
promised that a helicopter will fly over
where you live and a bunch of commandos
will jump down and execute everybody in
that facility that's the promise you get
that's what those are our deliverables
let's do it so they don't like it they
don't like kidnapping Americans do you
know what you like Germany and Spain
say what we will pay immediately well so
they
of kidnapping them but those people are
safe and then they pay for it nah man so
I went through that hostile environment
action whatever it's called training you
know and they told us straight up that
if you are captured and you know first
and foremost you have to assess your own
situation can you escape feign illness
you know whatever for the most part
however they said rest assured Americans
who are kidnapped have an extremely high
chance of extremely high like and plus
ninety percent percentage of rescue
because of the American government wants
it to be known that if American is taken
you are dead so they don't they don't
always and sometimes sometimes it takes
a really really long time so depending
on the on who's kidnapped you whether
it's a governmental force or it's you
know randos like random people like
random terrorists something yeah they're
coming for you and it gets really
difficult when it's a government like
Iran or Venezuela or North Korea but
when it's journalists you know in
certain areas man I I know some people
who have been rescued by the State
Department really crazy stuff dude I
know somebody somebody who is in Libya
when when the Gaddafi stuff was going
down and the US government sent in a
helicopter for him like I'm like what
and I'm like just for you and they're
like they evacuated Americans like they
they knew that there were some Americans
that were there and they got a bunch
people out uh-huh yeah and I'm like
that's crazy man flew you out so these
are stories that I've heard some
journalists have told me that after
kidnappings like yeah ålesund yeah
helicopter bro and and and these people
are worried that someone's gonna drop
down and it's gonna be a bunch of you
know it's gonna be SEAL Team six and
that's not who you want to meet
definitely not not not worth it no way
we do the opposite our own country we
tell them oh yeah you burn stuff you
blow it you blow it up you know we got
you will give you what you want it's
it's it's a horrifying lesson to the
law-abiding citizen to this country
who've lost their businesses and and and
the loved ones of people like you know
David Dorn for instance yeah who now to
see the suffering meanwhile in the media
they praise that Chris Cuomo praises it
these people are gross Chris comas at
joke yep thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. if you want to catch the full
show
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you